Speaker 1: So a little later in today's show,
we're going to talk about the 2022 midterm
outlook, kind of looking into the 2024 election
outlook.
There's some interesting things going on.
Already interesting polling, interesting betting
numbers and a lot of different things.
The context in which this happening is a in
which this is happening is a series of increasingly
unhinged candidates, many of them supported
by the failed former President Donald Trump.
And one such example of what we're seeing,
we saw this weekend as Donald Trump flew up
to Anchorage, Alaska, to hold a rally really
just in opposition to Lisa murkowski.
Lisa murkowski is the current Alaska senator.
She is a Republican, but she is a Republican
that is not particularly deferential to Donald
Trump.
And if that's the case, Trump doesn't like
you and Trump will try to get you booted out
of office.
And that's exactly what Donald Trump did in
Alaska.
He also had Sarah Palin, former vice presidential
candidate and current congressional candidate
Sarah Palin speak at the event.
We're going to look at it.
I will tell you, many of these clips are extraordinarily
disturbing in how stupid they indicate the
country has gotten.
Now, one of the things Donald Trump did is
he used the F-word.
And it's very cool, I guess, when you're a
Republican to use the F-word, even if you're
a presidential candidate or a former president,
even though the Republican Party claims to
be the party of civility and moral values
and pro-family and Christianity and godliness
and decency and character, they love the F-bomb.
And just imagine, as you watch and listen
to this clip, how would they have reacted
if Barack Obama had dropped an F-bomb in a
speech?
I mean, remember, once Barack Obama didn't
wear a suit jacket in the Oval Office and
they went bonkers once Barack Obama put his
feet up on the desk in the Oval Office and
they said, this is such a disgrace, and here
it's very different.
Here they cheer it and they love it.
Speaker 2: So it hit them on the left and
hit them on the right and had them in the
center.
Sir Rex.
Speaker 1: That's pretty cool, right?
When the president swears it's very relatable
and he's a man of the people and all of this
stuff.
Now, maybe the epitome of the cult moment,
we've we've talked many times.
This is a cult.
There's no question that this is the cult.
They deify Trump in a way that is completely
cult like.
But this is maybe the epitome, starting with
a glitch.
Trump tried to start his conclusion, which
he always does by saying in conclusion, and
he almost said in collusion, he glitched very
badly one of these brain glitches, and in
order to cover it, he immediately aborted
the teleprompter, read and started talking
about a couple.
Or it might be a son and it might be a mother
and son, or it might be a couple.
I genuinely can't tell what it is.
He who were wearing shirts that have Trump's
face all over them, he talked about how he
wants their shirt and they I guess he was
kind of kidding, but they quite literally
took their shirts off.
These are the shirts they wore.
They took them off to give the shirt to Trump.
So this all starts with Trump glitching badly
on in conclusion, and it goes downhill very
quickly.
And look at the cultish nature of this interview.
Speaker 2: I love this guy's shirt.
I don't know.
I'd love to have you get up.
Come on, get up here.
Let me see.
Get up.
You get this guy up, you'll come in.
I love this guy.
Any guy wears a shirt like that.
How can you not love him?
Look at that.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Will you help him up?
Taylor, help him up.
Come on, you're a strong guy.
Come in.
I just want.
Speaker 1: And you'll notice that as these
people come up, they look visibly disoriented
by what's going on.
Speaker 2: I like that one.
I want this shirt I'm going to wear to the
next rally.
Speaker 1: Now you and I can tell that's a
joke, but they end up taking their shirts
off, and.
Speaker 2: I want to.
Speaker 1: And honestly, if you're only listening,
you're probably better off because of the
cringe.
And what we're seeing here is bizarre.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
I want that shirt.
Speaker 1: All right.
So moments later, they actually did take their
shirts off.
And we have an image of these individuals.
And the image has not been Photoshopped.
They they took their shirts off.
And it is the epitome, the epitome of the
cult moment.
Back to some more substantial things.
Donald Trump is now afraid to even use the
word vaccine.
This is very interesting.
And this next clip, Donald Trump tries to
take credit for the things he did during the
pandemic.
And one of the things Trump loves to take
credit for is the vaccine.
He doesn't actually say the word.
He says.
We did it much faster than they said we would.
But he doesn't say vaccine because his audience
is so anti-vax.
We did a.
Speaker 2: Hell of a job.
Never got credit for that.
More people died under Biden.
You saw that.
And the job we did with COVID, or as some
people call it, to be more accurate, the China
virus.
But we did so much in terms of therapeutics,
in a word that I'm not allowed to mention,
but I'm still proud of.
Speaker 1: That word is he's not allowed to
mention it, but he's proud of it because we
did it.
Speaker 2: We did that.
We did that in nine months that it was supposed
to take five years, that 12 years, nobody
else could have done it.
But I'm not mentioning it in front of my people,
but that's interesting.
Speaker 1: He's he's conceding if he uses
the word vaccine in front of his people, they
will boo.
But that thing that thing we did in months
instead of years, another moment.
This is a classic Trump always trying to be
relatable.
So he will mention places in the state where
he's speaking here.
He says, let's go to inside passage.
Speaker 2: Slopes of Denali to the waters
of Glacier Bay.
That's a beautiful place.
And from the fires of the interior to the
majestic vistas of the inside passage.
Does anybody know the inside passage?
Anybody want to go there tonight?
Bright, beautiful name the inside.
Let's go to the inside passage tonight.
Speaker 1: You can tell Trump really familiar
with the state of Alaska.
Based on that, a number of verbal misfires
here.
He referred to the newest Supreme Court justice,
Catanese, Brown, Jackson, as could change.
Speaker 2: She voted to approve Joe Biden's
radical left justice change.
Brown Jackson, the most far left justice in
history.
Speaker 1: Arguably the most qualified justice
in history.
Another misfire, just a very glitchy evening
for Trump.
Trump trying to say Elon Musk.
And he says, Leon, and it all goes downhill
Leon.
Speaker 2: I tell you what, Elon.
Elon.
Right.
Is not going to buy Twitter.
When did you hear that?
Before, Leon.
I tell you what.
Speaker 1: Leon.
And then lastly, now a staple of these rallies,
the overt, crass, transphobic portion of the
speech.
Speaker 2: We will also keep men out of women's
sports.
Oh.
Speaker 1: Major issue.
Speaker 2: Right.
The swimmer, the young swimmer.
She wanted to break that record.
1/16 of a second, she was going to do it.
And she looked over and she said hello to
people that she's grown up when she's seen
him.
She's a top, top swimmer.
She looks left and she sees him.
Hi.
You know, they hate each other, but they're
you know, they're competing high, high.
They hate her.
She hates them.
That's the way life goes, right?
Then she looks over waves, and then she sees
this guy.
You say?
They say, I mean, this is supposed to be a
technically correct term.
A person with a man's body.
Okay.
It's a man's body.
So they see this person with a man's body
and he's a giant.
He's a big guy, wingspan.
Speaker 1: I'm not even going to do the rest
of it because it's so overtly crass and horrifying.
But that is now a staple of these events.
So Alaska, a rally in Alaska, everything going
horribly wrong.
And then it became Sarah Palin's opportunity
to speak.
And let's talk about
that next.